علي رضا اكبر وزاره الاستخبارات الايرانيه
بيجاسوس من العيار الثقيل اعتقلت قبل ثلاث
سنوات واعدمته ايران بعد لائحه اتهام كانت
ثقيله تفصل السلطه القضائيه التهام وتقول
انه كان يتجسس لصالح الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ويمدها بمعلومات عن الاماكن
الحساسه في ايران مسؤوليه الرجل في النظام
الايراني ربما تزيد اهميه المعلومات التي
نقلها كما تقول الاستخبارات فقد شغل اكبر
مناصب حساسه في وزاره الدفاع والقوه
المسلحه وهو على علاقه بامين مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني
فقد حملتها طهرا مسؤوليه تتعياتي ما تصفه
بتجديد احد مسؤولها السابقين وطلبتها
بتوضيح وهي تستدعي سفيره بريطانيا
تفتح ملفات ما حدث ايران بعد اعتقال اكبر
اغتيل العالم النووي فخري زاد والسهدفت
مقار نوويه لم تربط ايران بين اعتقاله هو
تلك الحوادث لكن يبقى السؤال عن حجم
المعلومات التي سربت من ايران عبر جواسيسه
الى جهه اجنبيه
قد يضلوا متواصلا ما دامت هناك ملفات
ساخنه بينهم لم تحسم حتى لحظه طهران